I feel very scholarly in the weirdest
decorated dorm
it's Wednesday yarn its grace and
there's a lot of things that I have to
talk to you about today you know I
really tried to organize my thoughts
before this video started and it just
doesn't help my brain is just like a
card catalog in a wind tunnel
there's no organizing anything so this
video is all about giving you some back
to school dorm decorating tips or for
those people that are going maybe not
back to school but live with another
human being here are some tips that you
can use to decorate your abode and stick
around till the end of the video because
I have a huge contest to talk to you
about that involves my book where is it
mama if you didn't know I wrote a book
that's available for free so grace is
good really proud of it decorating your
dorm is one of the foremost reasons to
go to college
target knows they give me every year and
I've been out of college since 2007 oh
[ __ ] I've been out of college for seven
years whoa that came in like a wrecking
ball thing about going to college and
getting your own dorm room is that the
first year usually for the most part you
don't get to choose who you live with
you're thrown into this tiny tiny area
where you have to share all of your
space and things with another human
being that might be great it might be
awful most of the time it's awful so I
thought that I would give you some
really cute dorm decor tips for
decorating things that really send a
message to your roommate but in a super
cute way what's that message stay the
shout of my things
for this first project are you gonna
need are some tiny decorative would
involves some paint a sponge brush stick
on letters numbers and string the first
thing we're gonna do is put down
something to protect our counter space
that we don't care about just kidding
yeah I'm gonna use printer paper instead
then we're gonna squeeze out some of our
paints and begin applying the paint to
the wooden balls in any kind of fashion
you want this is entirely up to you but
coat each ball completely it just makes
the balls extra cute and who doesn't
like a cute ball once they're all
painted we're gonna take the wooden
balls and stick some letters on them you
can choose any letters you want to spell
out whatever you want it's entirely up
to you balls with letters on them well I
never after the letters are on we're
gonna take a piece of string and string
the balls on until we have finally our
message it's cute it's easy and you can
put thumbtacks on either side and hang
it on a wall
for this next project we're gonna need
some paint a sponge brush paint markers
to stick on letters and numbers and a
decorative piece of wood I got this one
at Michaels
you're gonna take your decorative piece
of wood and paint it any way you want
who doesn't like their wood painted
paint on wood well I never then we're
gonna take our paint pens and add some
more specific details this is entirely
up to you you don't have to do this you
live in a free country I hope then we're
gonna take our stick on letters and add
an extra special message and look how
cute that is you could hang this on a
wall you could put it in your roommates
bed whatever you want
this last one is super simple we just
need our paint pens and I found this
foam finger at Michael's for really
cheap you're gonna take your paint pens
and paint whatever you want on your foam
finger mine ended up pretty cute if I do
say so myself and there you go
there's some super simple super cheap
dorm decor that's sure to get your
roommate thinking that you're super
passive-aggressive today go there were
your dorm decorating tips and or just
your cohabitating decorating tips for
you to create some sort of boundaries
between you and your roommate but like
super cute boundaries now on to the big
book contest
yes I wrote a book called Grace's guide
and if you didn't know how dare you I've
been talking about it so much my book
Grace's guide the art of pretending to
be a grown-up is now available for
pre-sale at Grace's guide book calm and
starting right now we are announcing the
big book contest that will be happening
from now until the release of the book
on October 21st if you preorder the book
and or have already pre-ordered the book
and go to Grace's guide book calm to
enter the sweepstakes water the prizes
great question 500 of you will be
receiving an autographed Grace's guide
book play making a sticker that goes on
your book that is signed I mean grace
Helbig the author of Grace's guide the
order pretending to be a grown-up 100w
will be receiving a Grace's guide
official poster 45 of you will be
winning a Google hangout with myself
grace Helbig the off of Grace's guide
the order pretending me a grown up and
one lucky winner will receive a
personalized video from me to them it's
gonna be a full dick and labia pictures
just thrown on out there but the best
part is that starting September 9th
until the end of the contest October
21st we will be announcing winners every
week those winners will win signed
posters and/or signed autographs from me
to you but if you win one of those
prizes you are still eligible for the
grand prizes could have been after
October 21st so make sure to preorder my
book at Grace's guide book calm and if
you already pre-ordered go to Grace's
get book calm and
sign up for the contest that's a book
with no studies at different places the
book is officially done it's officially
done this is still a template like the
back isn't on this like this is like the
bribes without the jacking up that's a
reference to say yes to the dress
Atlanta I'm getting a copy of the book
soon and you will see in a video when I
get the copy I am so excited I think I'm
gonna start reading you some snippets of
the book in different videos over the
course of the next couple weeks I I've
been so busy that I haven't had a moment
to like settle in and actually
acknowledge the fact that there's stuff
in writing that I wrote in a book form
and it will be available for you guys to
read it and hopefully like take away
knowledge from if I didn't know me I
would send this book to friends and
enemies as gifts I don't know no Don oh
my god why did they create this
labyrinth to get through to get to the
book I should just turn off the video
but no don't get in Scouten buy her back